you
there's been a boom in mega churches
with thousands of members over the past
two decades but that massive growth has
come with a cost the survey of pastors
shows the demands of the jobs are
creating greater stress and some pastors
are just feeling overwhelmed and even
burned out CBS News special
correspondent James Brown is here with
the story of a popular young pastor who
decided to just take a break two years
ago we met pastor Howard John Wesley the
dynamic leader of the historic Alpha
Street Baptist Church in Alexandria
Virginia he's a gifted preacher teacher
who uses popular culture in his messages
to young people but he told his 10,000
member congregation that he's tired
there's not been a day in these past
eleven years that I have not woken up
and knew that there's something I had to
do for the church that I have to be
available for call that that our journey
with people through the highest and the
lows of life now I want you to hear me
clearly I'm not exhausted I'm tired
there's a difference with those words
Howard John Wesley announced that he is
taking a three and a half month
sabbatical from the church he loves I'm
just tired running a little bit on empty
and the distinction between tired and
burned out to you is a joy I've not lost
my joy there's just some of the fatigue
that comes along with it that requires
re plugging in and charging up so I can
continue to do what I think I've been
called to do
11 years ago pastor Wesley was called to
lead Alpha Street Baptist Church and he
has done it well church membership has
quadrupled to ten thousand during his
tenure but the demands some self-imposed
have taken a toll on the fourth
generation preacher did you feel
compelled to work 24/7 it's the only
model I've ever known I was raised by a
dad who God rest his soul told me never
turned down a preach engagement and Here
I am at 47 with 21 years in pastoring
and going maybe that wasn't the best
advice that collar that robe doesn't
grant you any immunity from mental
disease and depression and anxiety
preacher burnout has been an issue in
the Christian community according to a
2015 survey of 1500 evangelical pastors
by LifeWay research 54 percent of
pastors feel their role is frequently
overwhelming 33 percent feel isolated
but 71 percent of churches have no plan
for a pastor to receive a periodic
sabbatical what pushed me this year was
that Pastor Jared Wilson took his life
in September Jared Wilson the associate
pastor at the 10,000 member harvest
Christian Fellowship in California died
by suicide he was just 30 years old
there's an unhealthy addiction just
standing in that pulpit you can delude
yourself into thinking that that's what
life is all about
we have Wesley admits that he sees a
therapist regularly and he plans to use
his sabbatical to begin a healthy
lifestyle of exercise a plant-based diet
and most of all tending to his own need
for personal time with God the greatest
thing that's come from that sermon and
the sabbatical is receiving hundreds of
emails and texts from other pastors who
said thank you I need to do this as well
do you feel freed released absolutely
absolutely because I'm not ashamed free
that I don't have to be Superman I don't
have to be perfect I don't have to be
super anointed every time I walk in this
building that I can be Howard John and
not just pastor Tony the congregation
welcomes a sabbatical that the pastor
needs as a matter of fact it starts on
January 1st and pastor Wesley will be
back just before Easter and the
pressures of being a pastor are immense
indeed no matter how big the flock this
is a trend that we're unfortunately
seeing across the board in churches big
and small yeah it's such an important
job it's not the kind of job you can
take a mental or physical break from
unless of course you get a sabbatical
like this one JB thank you very much